Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we will see how and what DeepMind's AI is
able to learn from a human, but with a twist!
And the twist is that we are going to remove the
human teacher from the game, and see what happens.
Is it just memorizing what the human does,
or is this AI capable of independent thought?
Their previous technique did something like
that, like guiding us to the bathroom, start
a band together, or even find out the limitations
of the physics within this virtual world.
However, there is a big difference. This
previous technique had time to study.
This one, not so much! This new one
has to do the learning on the job.
Oh yes, in this project, we will see an
AI that has no pre-collected human data.
It really has to learn everything on the
job. So, can it? Well, let's see together!
Phase 1 - Pandemonium. Here, the
AI says, well, here we do…things,
I am not so sure. Occasionally, it gets a point,
but now, look, uh-oh! The red teacher is gone.
And…oh boy, it gets very confused. It does
not have much of an idea what is going on.
But, a bit of learning happens, and later.
Phase 2 - Following. It is still still
not sure what is going on, but
when it follows this red chap,
it realized that it is getting a much
higher score. Before, it only got 2, now,
look at it! It is learning something new
here. And, look! He is gone again, but
it knows what to do. Well, kind of. It still
probably wonders, why its score is decreasing?
So, a bit later, Phase 3 - Memorization. First,
the usual dance with the demonstrator. But, now,
when he is gone, it knows exactly what to
do, and just keeps improving its score.
And then comes the crown jewel. Phase
4 - Independence. No demonstrator
anywhere to be seen. This is the final
exam. It has to be able to independently
solve the problem. But here comes the twist.
For the previous phase, we said memorization,
and for this, we say independence. Why is this
different? Well, look. Do you see the difference?
Hold on to your papers, because we have switched
up the colors. So, the previous strategy
is suddenly useless. Oh yes! If it walks the same
path as before, it will not get a good score,
and initially, that's what it is trying to
do. But, over time, it is now able to learn
independently, and indeed, find
the correct order by itself.
And, what I absolutely loved here is, look.
Over time, the charts verify that indeed,
as soon as we take away the teacher, it
starts using different neurons as right
after becoming an independent entity.
I love it. What an incredible chart.
And all this is excellent news. So, if
it really has an intelligence of sorts,
it has to be able to deal with
previously unseen conditions and
problems. That sounds super fun
- let’s explore that some more.
Let’s give it a horizontal obstacle.
Good! Not a problem. Vertical?
Also fine. Now, let’s make the world larger! And,
it is still doing well. Awesome! So, I absolutely
love this paper. DeepMind demonstrated that
they can build an AI that learns on the job,
one that is even capable of independent thought,
and even better, one that can deal with unforeseen
situations too. What a time to be alive!
So, what do you think? What
else could this be useful for?
What do you expect to happen a
couple more papers down the line?
Please let me know in the comments
below. I’d love to hear your thoughts.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!